are the four lengths of the sides of a
quadrilateral enough to define a
quadrilateral uniquely let us see this
practically suppose I've got four sticks
and we are making a quadrilateral is
this the only quadrilateral possible
let's see no you can see it's moving so
what does that mean that we need at
least one more element so as to Define
this quadrilateral uniquely so if we add
one more stick and suppose we are
joining the
one pair of opposite vertices where you
can see that we are not able to move it
what does it mean that if the lens of
the four sides of a quadrilateral and
one diagonal is given the quadrilateral
can be defined uniquely thank you
foreign